[Music]
[Applause]
demarco far rams radio network sideline
reporter won a super bowl rams over the
titans you got the rams visiting the
buccaneers sunday nfc divisional
playoffs kick off at 3 eastern demarco
how you feeling brother i'm good mr
patrick how are you sir i'm i'm good
when's the last time you hit somebody
oh god like you know legally or
illegally
well either
might be a better story well i'm not
going to tell you the other one but yeah
i mean it's been about 20 years yeah
since i tackled somebody yeah no doubt
how is that
it's weird though that you spend what 20
years of your life hitting people yeah
and then you have to stop hitting people
you know it's it's it's it's something
you have to learn um
when you're playing
football you really get a chance to take
your aggressions out and then when it's
done you have to learn how to like talk
you know
how many hall of famers did you suck
oh god steve young
i never got jim kelly but i got fined
for drilling him i think i touched elway
on a sack
uh warren moon uh a couple a few elway i
i touched him down or he got away brett
favre twice
few hall of fame guys yeah did you talk
to him
you know i tried to talk to jim kelly
um he kind of like set me straight
because i blasted him in st louis on
that hard turf and you know when you run
through a guy you know when it hurts a
guy i can hear his like back crack so i
got up and said yeah baby how'd that
feel and he looked at me and says i've
been hit by better than you
and it just it just
took everything out of me
i went from this you know this rampaging
beast to this little kid back in the
sixth grade so yeah that's weird warren
moon tried to talk me out of a game
because we go back to washington so he
kept bringing up stuff from my past like
trying to keep me from being aggressive
wait during the game like he would just
throw something out
throw something out he he he brought up
don james which is always a soft spot
then he brought up jim lambred he
brought up where i lived in mcmahon hall
at uw i mean all this udub stuff you
know it just it kept me from like
wanting to
break his leg or something best lineman
you went against
oh man randall mcdaniel uh and bruce
matthews uh if you ask me the the first
two plays of the super bowl uh in
atlanta i couldn't tell you i was on my
face with bruce matthews on my back
uh so bruce matthews randy mcdaniel
absolutely the best ever randall
mcdaniel with that ugly ass stance i'm
sorry uh you look at it and say there's
no way he can get me from there and then
boom he's on your shoulder
it's setting up for disappointment in
tampa
and follow me on this because i think
the rams are the better team
and everybody is embracing the rams that
makes me a little nervous when you go
against tom brady i know they got line
issues you got two top receivers godwin
and brown not in i don't know how good
uh leonard fournette's going to be
too many people like the rams here
what do you think that makes you nervous
i'm with you a little bit a little bit
yeah you you've been in this biz a long
time to you know when when everyone
thinks you're going to win i mean that's
it just gives bulletin board material to
the other side and tom brady is sitting
over there so
uh the people the fact that people favor
rams right now
it's it's it doesn't even get into my
kitchen uh it's tom brady and you're
going to his house he are he is the
defending champs i said this right after
we left sophie when the the rams beat
arizona
great game your your gift for beating
the arizona cardinals is you get the
defending champs at their house next
week
the nfl is doing you no favors you did
yourself no favors with that so
favor in the rams good but it's still
going to be a tough out no matter what
rams win this game because of defense or
offense
hopefully because offense really um i
hope the the good matthew stafford you
know shows up the one we saw in arizona
the one that is great behind the running
game where you don't have to put it up
35 40 times
the one that doesn't turn the ball over
and put your defense in bad situations
so i hope it's the offense i hope cam
akers coming back
has as much impact as it did versus
arizona i hope sony michelle being uh
sharing the load at running back is
going to kind of keep the offense on on
pace on schedule and the defense off
balance if you've got to throw it and
it becomes a passing game between brady
and stafford that's
i wouldn't want that for anybody's
quarterback i really wouldn't i wouldn't
want that pressure so i hope the running
game is there to kind of pace it help
sean mcvay call a better game and you
keep brady on the sidelines for as long
as possible who is odell beckham now
as a man he's a star uh if there was
ever a guy yeah and you've been out here
to los angeles you know what this is all
about what this city is about and so
plop an nfl football team here that's
trying to grow its fan base he's perfect
for this environment he's a great
athlete he's tremendous he's he's must
watch he's much ctv and he's he's a
pretty damn good receiver too i mean
that touchdown pass he caught for
matthew stafford where he went up and
over the corner
not many guys can do that with that body
control so the guy makes catches he's
got big hands he's bigger than what you
think and he's a star when he takes his
helmet off he gets
the same reaction as when he has it on
they just love him here
um at their best jalen ramsey or aaron
donald if you're starting your team
whoo
uh a.d um and that's that's hard um
a.d because i've seen him do it longer
and he's he's headed the canton um
everybody i've talked to john randall to
warren zapp to all the the special guys
that i came up with uh they all say the
same thing they've never seen anything
like this he's he's he's awesome uh but
that's still tough because jalen ramsey
here's a guy who just loves the violence
of the game he really does um he's a
corner but he plays it like a safety and
he coaches it like he's a coordinator
and he has the presence of an outside
linebacker you don't see guys like that
too often i keep wondering i keep saying
this to maurice jones drew how the heck
did jacksonville let him go
really that you don't let talents like
this leave so
good but randy forced his way out he
didn't want to stay there well i mean
you could with a guy this good i would
just turn a blind eye to what he says or
what he does and i try to make him happy
because you want him on the field he's
been a difference maker i mean at times
he's been your best defensive player
even with 99 but to answer your question
i'd have to start with aaron donald
that's why the the draft is so
unscientific certainly at quarterbacks
but how many teams passed on aaron
donald
like what was it that they they didn't
see because i always say that gm sort of
talk themselves out of drafting a player
because they look at the negatives more
than what he does well they look at what
he doesn't do well you know this is
funny and um i i was kind of there in
the area when they were debating aaron
donald and it was split
you know i never heard this before he's
a change of pace defensive tackle what
the heck does that mean you know i've
never heard that but i mean all they
kept looking at was his dimensions he's
only six feet six feet one about 285 on
a heavy day on a good day
but if you just look at that you'd say
okay we can't take him in the first
round he's not big enough but then you
turn on the film of the senior bull and
no one touched him no one can block him
he's the best player at the senior bowl
so why wouldn't you draft him so it was
split down the middle and i'm glad the
the the right side won because and even
when they drafted him he had to wait to
start
they just didn't i mean really it was
just it was just strange i mean the guy
has been aaron donald since day one and
he had to wait to start but as soon as
they let him go you haven't stopped them
since but they also missed on cooper cup
all these teams
uh you know i think being white playing
at eastern washington um hey he's not
he's a four six guy
um you know he's not like a a wes welker
edelman because he's so much bigger than
those guys uh so why why do you think
teams passed on cooper cup you know this
is why steve sarkeesian will i mean
it's hard for me like to like him
because cooper cup was right up there in
in washington and we missed the huskies
missed on him he's right there uh same
with all the the pacific northwest teams
you missed on him but from what i hear
he just didn't look the part in high
school he just didn't look like a guy
that could play but when you turn on the
film the guy can play so i guess it's
easy to overlook and the white thing is
funny you know that lasted about a half
a practice here and you know how some
corners are when they see guys like
cooper cup you know step up in that line
oh my god this is going to be an easy
day they give you the look
so tremaine johnson was the rams corner
and he was kind of our resident tough
guy we couldn't wait for this matchup
cup versus tremaine and the first pass
in one on ones he spun tremaine into a
hole caught a touchdown pass and then
like kind of laid the ball down tremaine
shook his hand like immediately so the
white stuff was gone then
you know done no more white guy this guy
can play you better treat him like every
other receiver it's funny well he was
still white
right yeah yeah yeah he was still yeah
white yeah getting the respect i asked
ricky paul the same thing um you know
what is that like and he said it's an
ongoing battle but with cooper cup you'd
never know it he's just out there
playing his game and it still feels like
he's underrated and he had one of the
greatest seasons of receivers ever had
yeah uh i think there's some jealousy
there because there was a concerted
effort to get him the football early
there were some problems early let's not
lie matthew stafford was looking for him
even robert woods when he was healthy
there was a game where he he showed his
frustration because there were guys open
and matthew stafford still tried to fit
the ball to cooper cup so they're trying
to get him in the football they're
trying to get him open he can get open
on his own uh even sean mcvay had said
that the offense runs through him now
you don't get head coaches saying that
often but it's true the offense does go
through cooper cup
it's always great to talk to you sorry i
haven't stayed in touch with you i
always appreciated your personality the
first time this is the first time that
you've actually interviewed me
the the last time we were together i
actually interviewed you you came to la
oh i think it was gary miller or kevin
kylie you came and now you said i was
profiling you because you said you had
like a 30-inch vertical and i didn't
believe you and you looked at me
i i still do i still have there's the
answer that i want to see yeah
uh safe travels thank you demarco you
got it man thank you that's uh demarco
farm rams radio network sideline
reporter and uh
i i remember talking to him at the
mothership we'd have him on and i just i
i forgot how good his personality is